Kimball's got popped in the head so a  three-point opportunity for Kemba Walker  but the records wasn't indicative of  what they could be kappa that's another  long two heads to the Scourge table  still the only Hornets to score in this  quarter that man right there  Kemba Walker and his former college  teammate Jeremy Lamb tempeh didn't like  what he saw long to Temba I heart to  take it caliber of play yeah about that  terms of longevity and productivity  Kemba Walker refusing to give up this  sick threat oh the heart of a lion  Temba he knew that Gobert has five fouls  and attacked him one before vigil five  of bagels come on good job  it doesn't stop all right let's see it  camping foots going up on the river did  not 41 points Oh fun fun player to watch  in the second half for Kemba Walker